[Müzik]
Herkese merhaba Ben Deniz emirheboğlu
namı diğer Otel faresi adlı kitabımdan
ötürü bu şekilde tanımıyorum sektörde
Tabii hikaye anlatmak keyifli ama en
hakim olduğunuz hikayeyi anlatmak daha
keyifli tabii ki ben de kendi hikayemi
anlatacağım
hop değişti
mekanı vardır Benim Hikayem 27 Mart 1971
yılında İstanbulda soğuk bir salı
sabahında başlıyor
sancıları artan anneme apar topar
taksiye bin lira babam
hastaneye doğru giderken saraçhaneci
civarında polisler taksi durduruyorlar
ve arama yapıyorlar Zira Deniz Gezmiş
arkadaşları Mahir Çayan ve diğer
arkadaşları hepsi hapisten kaçmışlar
Bütün Türkiye'de ve İstanbul'da
Dolayısıyla fellik fellik onları
arıyorlar Eğer polis memuru taksiyi bir
an önce açıp da annemin hastaneye
gitmesini sağlamazsa Benim Hikayem
taksinin arka koltuğunda Doğan Emir
olarak başlayacaktı
68 ruhunun heyecanı ve o enerjisiyle ilk
aklımız derdinde tanıştırılan Biz
70'lere geldiğimizde memlekette toz
duman ve kargaşanın ortasında kaldık
Çünkü Anarşi denilen bir şey vardı ve
Anarşi yapanlara da anarşik diyorduk
anarşist istemiyorduk halk arasında
anarşik deniyordu memleket Fight Club
seti gibiydi ve sürekli yumruk yiyorduk
Öyle ki Sabahları okula giderken haftada
en az iki kere istanbul'dayken bir
çatışmaya denk geliyorduk
öğrenci evi polisler klasik çatışmalar
Hatta Öyle ki çatışmanın arasından
geçerken polis amcalar oradaki terörist
ya da anarşist dediğimiz arkadaşlara
durmalarını söylüyor öğrenci olarak biz
aralarından geçiyoruz 100-150 metre
gittikten sonra da arkadan çatışma
sesini tekrar duyuyorduk işte böyle
enteresan günlere denk geldi benim
doğumum
Mahalle kaderdir
Biz çok fakirdik
Sabahları kilometrelerce yol yürür
Kardeşimle birlikte türlü tehlikeler
atlatarak okula giderdik Akşamları gaz
lambasının altında Ders yapmaya çalışır
çoğu zamanda aç yatardık yalan alakası
yok Ne fakirlik ne de çok zengindik orta
direk denilen bir terim vardı bizde aile
olarak o orta direğin direğin üst
taraflarında bir yerde yaşayan bir
aileydik teşvikiyede yaşıyorduk çok
mutena çok güzel bir semttir İstanbul'da
genelde herkesin yaşadığı şehirle ilgili
bir aşk ya da bir nefret ilişkisi vardır
benim de İstanbulla ilgili böyle aşk ve
Nefret ilişkim devam etti yıllar boyu
sürekli ondan Kaçtım ama sürekli geri
dönmek zorunda kaldım Çünkü kalmak için
değil gitmek için doğmuştum her gün
sömestrda her gün her sabah
Teşvikiye Caminin yanındaki donmuş
durağından 1950 model
dolmuşlara binerek Karaköy güllüoğlu'nun
önünde inerdim Zira
eğer o sömestr tatil programınız yoksa
Karaköy'e gider Dükkanı açardık
babamızın dükkanına rutin şöyle işlerdi
dolmuşa binersin dolmuşu kaçırdıysan
troleybüse yani elektrikli otobüse
binersin Güllü olanın önünde inersin
güzel bir sıcak su böreği sıcak süt
Besmele çekip Dükkanı kepengeni açarsın
dükkan temizlenir dükkanın öyle de
süpürülür adettendir esnafsın sonra
tabure koyar ve kendine bir oralet
söyleyip babanın gelişini beklersin
Karaköy Perşembe Pazarı benim turizmden
önceki hayatımda çok önemli yeri olan
bir yer Zira Karaköy perşembe pazarında
taradığım karakterler insanlar ki
bunların arasında Alyanak Ahmet cımbız
Mehmet tombalacı Turan Serdar Hayko
abi armana kahveye ve türlü karakter
vardır yıllar sonra aldığım beden dili
kardeşim bir dolu eğitimin ardından şuna
kanaat getirdim ki orada öğrendiğim Yani
insana ve hayata dair öğrendim hiçbir
şeyi bana diğer eğitimler vermedi Zira
komşularımız arasında Süryaniler
Ermeniler Yahudiler
Lazlar Kürtler Araplar her etnik çeşitli
insan tipinden bir komşumuz vardı ve ben
bunların bazılarıyla çalışma fırsatı
yakaladım Ki Hayko abi bunların en
önemlilerinden en önemli figürlerden bir
tanesiydi benim için Çünkü halka halka
abinin yanında bir dönem çalıştım vapur
sirenini yapıyorduk
şeyi de atları vapurlarına vapur
sirenini yapıyorduk ve ben yaklaşık
birkaç hafta sonra onun yanına girdikten
sonra vapur sireni yapmayı öğrendim
kollu bir mekanizmadır iki tane çarkı
vardır havanın sıkışmasıyla birlikte
çıkan o ince ses size çok rahatsız edici
bir ses verir ama denizde duyulması için
de bu elzemdir yaklaşık birkaç hafta
sonra Hayko abi bana bir paket bantlı
bir paket bir koli bir şey verdi ve bunu
nuru Osmaniye Caminin yanındaki Süryani
bir kuyumcuya götürmemi söyledi
götürdüm oradan aldığım paketi de geri
getirdim alko abiye teslim ettim birkaç
hafta boyunca bu böyle devam etti Ben
tabi olayın mevzusunu Anlamadığım için
bir gün Galata köprüsünün altında umumi
tuvalete girerek götürdüğüm Paketi açtım
İçinden Bir demet dolar çıktı
kapattım bantladım Hiç belli olmasın
diye Süryani kuyumcuya götürüp teslim
ettim sonra Diğer paketi aldım tekrar o
tuvalette açtım onu ve içinde Türk
Lirası vardı yıl 80 Turgut Özal henüz
Başbakan değil Başbakanlık müsteşarı ve
döviz yasak Yani ben bir çeşit kuryelik
yapıyordum Bu da benim için İlk defa
enteresan bir deneyimdi hava atarak
kendime bir şey zannederek gangster gibi
hissederek dükkana geldim babamı
anlattım sonuç ne oldu babam babam Hayko
abiye Hayko Abi babama vardı ikisi de
dönüp bana bağırdı ve ben Kovuldum ilk
oğlunla deneyimim de buydu özallı yıllar
Bu arada benim Turizm otelcilikle ilgili
de
Hikayem başlıyor
merhum Turgut özal'la ilk karşılaşmam ki
Türkiye siyasi hayatının önemli bir
figürdür ışık Lisesi'nde oğlu Efe
Özal'ın mezuniyet törenine denk geliyor
çok kalabalıklı mahallede herkes
gitmiştir bizde Turgut özal'ı göreceğiz
diye gitmiş ve sırada bekliyorduk makam
arabası yanaştı korumaları kapıyı açtı
ve kendisi indi halkı selamladı
Dolayısıyla halkın arasında bende var
benim de Selamünaleyküm
yaptı sonra vazgeçti geldi Kimileri ile
el sıkıştı çivilerin de başını okşadı
sevdi ilk defa bir başbakan tarafından
okşanmıştım enteresan bir hikayeydi
denemeyen yaşamayan bilemez
yıllar sonra Antalya dedemanlar
çalışıyor itibariyle Ben de stajyer
olarak Antalya'dayım
eşi Semra Hanım'la Beraber otele teşrif
buyurdular
Kral dairesinin önündeki birkaç Otel
görevlisinden biri de benim odadan
kahvaltılar çıkartılacak ama koruma
görevlileri Efendi departmanından
kimseyi bulamamışlar bir tanesi tuttu
beni içeri attı O heyecanla girdim
kimseyi görmedim O çok rahat dedim
tabakları boşları alıyorum Rum servis
arabasına koyup kaçacağım aldım koydum
aldım koydum o sırada Turgut özal'la göz
göze geldik dedim gene okuyacak okşamadı
aksine gazetesini istedi gazetesine
verdim teşekkür etti çıktım Rum servis
arabasıyla servis kapısını açıp içeri
girdim ne göreyim genel müdürümüz dahil
bütün otel yönetimi orada ve sorular
sordular gazetesini istedim ve
kahvaltısını ettiğimi Semra Hanım bir
şey isterimi hepsini cevapladım sorun
yok Sonra enteresan bir şey gerçekleşti
ve genel müdürümüz dahil bütün departman
yöneticileri
kahvaltısına saldırdı yarım kalan
peynirler yarım kalan kruvasanlar
çörekler şunlar bunlar hepsini yemeye
başladılar ben tabi aval avalıyorum ne
oluyor derken rahmetli Ömer bey bana
dedi ki Oğlum ağzını kapat dedi bu dedi
Senin bildiğin gibi bir şey değil bu Bir
modda dururcilikte var mı hala
araştırıyorum duymadım daha önce böyle
bir şey bana dedi ki büyük adamın
kahvaltısından yemeğinden yersen ileride
sende büyük adam olma ihtimali çok
yüksek
ekmek sepetine takıldı tek bir kuralasam
kalmıştı ulan dedim acaba
denedim şansımı Ama hiçbir altta
yaradığına inanmıyorum ve bu arada sana
89 hayatında bir dolu İlk var ilk defa
18 yaşında evden çıkmışım tek başıma
Vallahi onu söyle herhalde yanlış
hatırlamıyorsam Taksim'den bindim otobüs
Antalya'da indim Antalya'ya geldim ilk
büyük aşkıma 89 senesinde Antalya'da
yaşadım diğerlerini ise sırayla Fethiye
Bodrum Marmaris Kuzey Kıbrıs Türk
Cumhuriyeti ve döngü olarak kısır döngü
tekrar Antalya'da yaşadım
ilk tacizimi ilk tacizime Otelci olarak
tacizlerimiz boldur bizim 19 yaşında
gene Antalya'da Bir otelde yaşadım
kat koridorunda yürüyorum o zaman
hulk'te çalışıyorum kirli taşıyorum
falan bir tane Amerikalı amca sonradan
öğrendim çünkü
oda listesine baktım kim olduğuna
amcanın birisi bekliyor
yarı Anladım İngilizceyi çok iyi
bilmiyorum Bana bir demet dolar sallıyor
ki dolarla ciddi ilişkin var
biliyorsunuz dolar sallıyor zaten dolara
konsantre oldum ve bana İngilizce
Kamir deyip odayı gösteriyor ilk önce
anlamadım saf temiz 18 yaşında küçücük
Ondan sonra adama beklediğini fark ettim
o dönemde Tabii olayı geç tahlil ettim
ve adamın elindeki parayı kaptım o ne
akıllısa koridorda uzaklaştım ve bu
arada ilk staj deneyimim ilk Otel
deneyimim ilk üniforma deneyimi ilk
paspas ilk oda yapımı ilk yatak yapamama
benim için hem çok çetelli hem zor hem
acayip eğlenceli bir mevzuydu salon
içerisine Bazı arkadaşlarımız var aynı
dönemde aynı otelde çalıştık neler
yaşadığımızı çok iyi bilirler tabi bu
arada Evrim devam ediyor
benim devrimim devam ediyor hem vücudum
değişiyor bedenim değişiyor saç tipim
değişiyor Hareketlerim değişiyor deyince
düşüncelerim değişiyor Ama bu arada
ülkede evriliyordu Türk turizmi
devriliyordu Türkiye'de evriliyordu
milyonlarca turist gelmeye başlamıştı
Her sene onlarca Otel açılıyor binlerce
insana iş ve istihdam sağlanıyordu ki
bunların hepsi paralel ilerliyordu
girişimcilik hikayeleri
bütün hayatım boyunca enteresan işler
yaptım garip birisi olarak bazen
nitelenmiş olabilirim ama şansımı
denemediğim hiçbir şey yok şöyle bir şey
bakıp listim var ve sürekli
güncelleniyor bu bakıp disk onu da
yapayım bunu da biraz iştahlı
olduğumu söyleyen midir ya pandemi
döneminde kendi kahve markamı Yarattım
diye ve 2 sene boyunca kolilerce kahve
sattım online ki online satıştan hiç
anlamam eşim dostum arkadaşlarım yardım
etti bal markası Yarattım markanın ismi
Hani baldı from Marmaris onu da sattım O
da çok keyifliydi Ve arkasından bir de
şapka tasarımı yaptım resmimi çok iyidir
Kimse bilmez bildiğinizden fazlasıyım
şapka tasarımı yaptım
semboller yaptım üzerine güzel desenler
çizdim ve başta Turizm sektörü olmak
üzere eşit olsun kim varsa sattım hiçbir
şekilde aç kalmak söz konusu değil radyo
programı yapmak istedim turizmle ilgili
bir radyo programı yaptım çok sevdiğim
insanlarla birlikte uzun sürdü çok da
keyifliydi televizyon programı yapmak
istedim çok sevdiğim insanların bana
yaptıkları desteklerle Bir de televizyon
programı yaptım bu da acayip keyifliydi
ama ruh doymuyor iki tane kitap
çıkarttım O kitaplarda Allah razı olsun
yayıncılarından da dostlardan da sağladı
ama
Tüm bu girişimcilik hikayelerim arasında
çoğunuzun ya da hiçbirinizin bilmediği
Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'nde
Yaşadığım bir enteresan olay var Bir web
sitesi kurdum Ben bir gün
manatından longayla giderken tren
bekliyorum Pen Station diye bir yer var
tren bekliyorum yaklaşık 10-12 Durak eve
kadar gideceğim
Otelcilik yapıyorum o zaman ben size
işine geldiğimde duvarda bir dolu ilan
gördüm ki burada adettendir işte piyano
dersi verenler gitar dersi verenler
köpek dolaştırmanızı isteyenler ya da
ilanları ya da muadil bunlardan
7-8 tanesini aldım trende giderken
okurum diye Bu arada her bir ilanın altı
da tırtık tırtık kesik orada telefon
numaraları var
alıyorsunuz arıyorsunuz hizmet
alıyorsunuz falan gibi
10-12 Durak bayağı vaktim var ilanlara
bakıyorum ilanlara Bakıyorum şu ilanı bu
ilanı ilanı Şimdi bir de yan
gelir ihtiyacım var benim yani otelde
çalışıyorsunuz bir para alıyorsunuz ama
saatlik birazcık daha paranın hiçbir
zararı yok kimseye Ondan sonra
ilanları fazlalaşmaya başlayınca tren
camındaki yansımamı gördüm Ulan dertler
gibi bir şeysin bunu seninle bir işi
olmaz Bunları Kenara koydum Bir tanesi
çok ilgimi çekti sadece yemek yemek için
sadece Şarap içmek için bara gitmek için
sadece broadway'de bir müzikal dinlemek
için ya da Central Park'ta at arabasıyla
dolaşırken Sıcak bir şeyler içelim
Sohbet etmek için bir hizmet sunuyordu
bu arkadaş bu acayip kafama yattı Tabi o
eve gidene kadar
bunların hepsini kafamda planladım
olabilitesini kendimce kanaat getirdim
ve eve gittim evde 4 kişi yaşıyoruz
Klasik Türk toplumuna benzin pompacısı
da var klasiktiren Amerika'da Garson da
var restoranda da var İşte o tercih de
var
yaklaşık bir iki gün içerisinde bir tane
web sitesi tasarladım İsmini Koydum
bütün arkadaşlarımın o 4 kişinin Ben
dahil fotoğraflarını küçük biyografi ve
birer tane yani kullanıt gibi telefon
numarası koydum ve götürdüm pense
station'daki bütün duvarlara astım saati
8 dolar 10 Dolar ne alsa 2 gün sonra
aramızdan iki kişiye
telefon geldi ve akşam onların
Buluşmaları gerçekleşti
sonra ne oldu vallahi bir daha bu işi
yapmamaya karar verdik
Çünkü anlatamayacağım şeyler oldu
ama deneyimdi şansımızı denedik olmadı
Yalnız şunu öğrendim Amerika gibi büyük
bir toplumda kocaman güçlü bir ülkede
insanların yalnız olduğunu ve insanların
böyle saçma sapan şeylere para
harcadığını ve bunların toplum olarak
mutlaka bir psikoloğa gitmeleri
gerektiğine kanaat getirdim
yazarım hem de çok iyi yazarım yani
yazarım derken yazar değilim yazıyorum
her şeyi yazıyorum sektördeki her şeyi
yazıyorum gördüklerimi duyduklarımı Bana
iletilenleri eleştirdiklerim her şeyi
yazıyorum ve her yazdıktan sonra da
mutlaka Bu salonda bulunan birkaç kişi
dahil olmak üzere tehdit Telefonları
alıyorum Yine mi bizi yazdın lan Emir
çünkü eleştiriyorum ama hiçbir şekilde
rencide etmiyorum isim vermiyorum tarif
vermiyorum geçtiğimiz seneydi galiba
Antalya Müzesinde
var o da hijyen biliyorsunuz artık
yapıyorsun kızı hijyen olsa olsa süper
olur ama babası
askereus tarafından kafasını atılan
şimşekle bayıltıldıktan sonra
Hayriye el vermiştir haycaya el almıştır
Bu da Anadolu kültüründe vardır ve Ares
sevdiğim karakter Ares Savaş tanrısıdır
emekli başçavuş olma ihtimali çok yüksek
güvenlik müdürü
teşekkür ederim
çok arkadaşım var böyle
Ares de Güneydoğu'da çatışmış olması
önemli Ondan sonracığıma bütün olimpos'a
hakim olur korur kollar çok güçlü bir
karakter
şimdi Yaşasın Turizm
Tabii bunların arasında
Sonuç olarak Total olarak neyi mi
başardım
ona da söylemek lazım Vallahi ben 52
yaşadık 2-52 yıllık kısa Bence kısa
yaşamın boyunca
biriktirdiğim insanlar dostlarım
arkadaşlarım hepsi benim için çok önemli
ve çok değerli ben insan biriktirmeye
çok meyilli bir adamım ve çok insan
biriktirdiği bir de iyi biliyorum O
yüzden ben kendi başıma insan
biriktirmek olarak addetmiş durumdayım
tabi bu arada beni turizme iten Annem
Fatma Sultan'a da buradan sizin önünüzde
teşekkür etmek istiyorum çünkü terlikle
kafama vura vura vura beni o tercihi
yaptı Sağ olsun var olsun dinlediğiniz
için teşekkür ederim efendim
[Müzik]